apex legends has a cheating problem
everyone knows it
hell as a free-to-play title it would be
strange if
everything was fine and the quote
unbannable king of
apex is this dude named tuffy who
quite frankly has become a minor
celebrity on the scene
hacking cheating and basically holding
high-level lobbies
hostage now i talked to him and
he has no intention of stopping
[Music]
all right do everything that we normally
tell you to do at this point in the
video
like the video leave a comment about my
hands
subscribe to the channel hit that
notification bell so you never miss new
content
again so apex legends the popular battle
royale that was brought to you by the
same people who made titanfall 1 and 2
has a massive cheating problem this is
not new information
since the game launched in february of
2019 apex legends has been plagued by
sweaty chuds looking to [ __ ] around and
ruin your good time
and we're not just talking about at the
silver level either it has a cheating
issue
all the way up its ranked ladder to apex
predator
the highest rank you can get and
honestly the coolest name for a ranked
level in
any game ever i mean come on apex
predator that is sick and this youtuber
hacker dude
tuffy he's well notorious for it
he made a new look how fast he made it
he was banned
he literally just got banned he got back
like
he look at what four minutes ago four
minutes ago he got banned
the main way tuffy cheats as you just
saw is through
aim blocks essentially using software
that allows him to
lock on to another player making it
extremely easy for him to take them out
now we aren't here to glorify cheating
that [ __ ] sucks
but for whatever reason portions of the
apex community love to talk this guy up
much to develop or respawn chagrin and
he's become
known for essentially being unbannable
but a little while ago apex streamer
rogue said some pretty wild stuff on
stream regarding
tuffy and some alleged impending legal
action
what happened to two people he's in jail
[Music]
that man is uh going through the court
process right now hearing that tuffy
might be in prison and
facing some substantial legal
consequences
the apex scene went nuts on one hand his
oddly gassed up fans couldn't believe
this
might be the end of their sadistic
entertainment on the other hand
popular streamers like imperial howe
would
frankly be more than happy to see him
gone except according to tuffy
that's not the case at all see rogue was
quick to follow up on his clip by
commenting on a reddit post and
stating that he was basically memeing on
tuffy being in prison on top of that
in now deleted tweets rogue basically
said that
he was just repeating a bunch of rumors
he saw floating around online
and that he has no idea if tuffy's being
sued or not
so i reached out both to ea and respawn
for comment about any potential legal
action
they might be taking against tuffy but
unfortunately
neither of them got backed me in time
for publication and to prove that he
wasn't in prison
which is a strange thing to have to
prove tuffy uploaded a video on may 10th
of him cheating in apex to somehow
give us evidence that he wasn't behind
bars
which again very strange
now you might be wondering why tuffy's
so notorious and
how he keeps getting away with his
pretty shitty antics
well i interviewed him so i'll let him
explain
sort of see because he's so blatantly
well
known as a cheater he and his discord
full of like-minded individuals
were extremely paranoid about him doing
any sort of recorded
interview so we didn't [ __ ] just to get
access to him i had to jump through a
bunch of different hoops
to prove who i am is who i say i am
but what i did do was conduct an
official written interview through
discord and i'll be relaying his answers
here
throughout also because english isn't
tuffy's first language
the interview quotes you'll be hearing
have been edited for clarity and brevity
now like i said tuffy is notorious for
using aim hacks
that part is pedestrian he locks onto
his target and
wipes everyone out and according to him
he's been using cheats in
apex for quite a while now quote i
started using cheats in season two i
think
because i was already cheating in pubg
when i started playing apex actually
legit
i was getting banned like every time
then i got my hardware id banned for
what i thought was no reason
but because i had pub g cheats installed
maybe that was the cause of it
i started with free cheats at the
beginning to know how it works
then i moved to a paid version also to
experience that
end quote what's interesting about the
27 year old belgian situation
is how he's able to cheat and blatantly
get away with it
and that's how he's essentially able to
hold high level lobbies
hostage see like most free to play games
it's
incredibly easy to cheat you cheat you
get
banned and then you just boot up another
free account and
keep on keeping on even instituting
hardware id
bands which is an incredibly aggressive
move on respawn's part and supposedly
the most
damning of consequences for cheaters is
apparently pretty easy to get around
in apex according to tuffy you just
essentially
spoof or fake your computer system and
then
go on about your day and the term
spoofing basically just means having
your device
pretending to be something that it's not
so in this case
spoofing essentially means faking your
pc's hardware information
and tricking response anti-cheat system
into thinking that
you're using a device that doesn't have
a hardware id ban
associated with it and like tuffy
mentioned a quick five-minute google
search will teach you everything you
need to know in order to pull this off
but don't do that now apex legends uses
something called easy anti-cheat
and if you've ever played fortnite you
might be familiar with it since it uses
the same
system easy anti-cheat is a kernel level
system
meaning it's installed deep into the
core of your computer's operating system
and this is done automatically for games
like apex and fortnite when you install
them
riot games as valorent also uses a
kernel level piece of software with its
proprietary anti-cheat system
vanguard and the whole point of using a
kernel type
anti-cheat is to catch cheaters at the
deepest level of your computer
theoretically making cheating programs
easier to
detect and harder to use we've done a
whole video on kernel level anti-cheat
software on this show back when valerian
originally dropped
according to gamerdoc if you actually
want to catch cheaters like you're
actually serious about this your
software
needs to be intrusive full stop if your
anti-cheat isn't
their cheat will be and you're sunk so
it's not like respawn are doing nothing
about it
in fact they're doing the exact opposite
they're doing everything they can
but the reality is it's one company
fighting the entire [ __ ] internet so
you know it's not an easily winnable
battle
here's what tuffy is doing specifically
him and others consistently find
ways to take brand new accounts that
they've created after they've been
banned and boost them into things called
predator
lobbies predator lobbies are a fancy way
of describing high-level players who
would literally
wipe the floor with my lifeline rogue
imperial hal
lg shiv and shroud are just a few of the
names you'll see if you ever make it up
there
now predator level players are only
supposed to play in predator level
lobbies
i say supposed to because apex legends's
ranked system
is another thing that's come under a lot
of fire since the game launched
to give you a very simple answer the
code for apex is
all sorts of scrambled and because of
that constantly mixes low-level players
with high-level players which for a
ranked experience
really should not be happening so you'll
often find that if you go on a hot
streak and put a bunch of wins together
at silver
3 it's not uncommon to find yourself
facing off against predator level
players
which again shouldn't be happening and
is the highest rank
in apex legends and according to tuffy
it's
pretty easy to take a brand new account
and basically hack your way into
predator lobbies
quote it's all the same security and
high ranked or low i am hardware id
banned
so it doesn't take much to ban my
accounts so even if i play legitimately
i get banned
so there's no point to play legit for me
when i can fight other cheaters and have
fun and high ranked
if respawn just made a unique server for
cheaters like on titanfall
2 it would be great end quote so now you
have this cheater who's built a
reputation for
being unbannable and for hacking his way
into high-level lobbies
and because nobody's been able to ban
him yet
he essentially makes these streamers and
high-level players
do whatever he wants like fist fight
each other like this is ufc 4 or some
[ __ ]
if they don't do his bidding he'll just
aim lock them to death
and make the experience a hellscape for
everyone involved
[Music]
did if he was trying to put on like a
[ __ ] ufc 3v3 match
now those apex streamers shiv imperial
hal
and rogue are furious that tuffy
continues to get away with cheating
and it makes sense since all three guys
primarily stream
apex for a living and because nobody
really has that shroud money
somebody constantly ruining your stream
is going to impact your livelihood
on top of screwing with streamers and
holding lobbies hostage
tuffy has also been accused of ddosing
official apex
tournaments which is something that he
actually denies
doing he was also recently involved in a
situation with shiv who's signed to
luminosity gaming
see tuffy had allegedly been harassing
shiv for months
locking him out of games locking him out
of his own account
and essentially making his apex
experience a living nightmare
back on april 22nd tuffy killed shiv
during a match and
that was the last straw for shiv he
fired off a bunch of insults towards the
hacker
some of which landed him in hot water
with twitch who handed shiv
a seven day suspension now he appealed
the ban
and stated that the mods didn't take the
full context of his angry rant into
account
and on april 25th according to shiv
twitch
in somewhat of a rare move actually
reversed his ban
towards the end of our interview i asked
tuffy if he would ever stop cheating if
he found out that respawn or ea
was actually going to come after him
legally and his answer
was basically nah quote someone proposed
the same thing and my response was
if they just unlock my hardware id ban
and unban a good account of mine that i
probably forgot the login for
i would then stop but if i stop nothing
will change
at least i'm the one who doesn't hide
anything and shows all the bugs i can do
respawn should point out these bugs and
try to fix them
like how am i still able to get into
high ranked lobbies with a low level
when will they fix something that is not
big and very little
you get my point end quote so will ea
and respawn actually take legal action
will tuffy's reign of terror ever come
to an
end i have no idea but if those two
things do
happen i'll be sure to let you know
colton we got a bunch of [ __ ]
bloopers so just destroy me
as usual just destroy me colton all
right
[Laughter]
we aren't here to glorify cheating that
[ __ ] sucks
but jesus christ excuse me
excuse me
colton is gonna crucify me in this end
board all right well